. Donald Trump's attorney general, William Barr,
is now calling Donald Trump's behavior a betrayal
of the presidency and also said yesterday that
Trump's orchestrating a mob to pressure Congress
is inexcusable. Now, again, the analysis is very
similar. Bar was Trump's unmitigated, unrepentant
henchmen for years. Bar deserves none of our
sympathy. Bar is bailing as the ship is sinking.
But it's still great to see him say this. Former
Attorney General William Barr is reported by the
Associated Press, says Donald Trump's conduct as
a violent mob of his supporters stormed the U.S.
Capitol was a, quote, betrayal of his office and
supporters. Barr said that orchestrating a mob to
pressure Congress is inexcusable. The statement
has been obtained by NBC News and the Associated
Press was the first to report on it. Notable, yes.
Do you tend to see a president denounce their vice
president and an attorney general denounce the
president that selected them? No, you don't.
And that is significant. But everything that's
happening right now is significant. Much of
what's happening right now is unprecedented.
We are in dangerous, unprecedented times
at the same time. Barres disgusting. Deserves
to never work again, and you will remember that
BA resigned last month and was replaced by
another loyalist and it happened shortly
after William Barr said there was no widespread
fraud that had any impact on the results of the
election. So these are strange times, but
let's not say William Barr is a good guy.
You know, people like John Bolton
and others who after the fact
say what was obviously true all along. I don't see
them as anything approximating heroes. I see them
as people who for as long as it was comfortable,
for as long as they could get away with it,
they were happy being in proximity to power and
having access to the president and having that
prestigious title. And then when it starts to
become a risk for their future, their career,
future, their political future, then they come
out and say something like this. So is William.
William Burroughs, obviously right.
William Burroughs completely right
in saying that what Donald Trump has
done is a betrayal. It's seditious,
it's arguably treasonous. There's no question
about it. But the idea that there is anything
morally admirable about what William Barr is
doing, throw that in the trash, forget about it. I